i identify as bisexual um at the time
i
did not know which was why it was so
weird for me that's sanjaya malakar
coming out as bisexual in a new podcast
interview sanjaya was a finalist on
season six of american idol and became a
household name overnight with many
discussing the then 17 year old's
sexuality i grew up in a time when
being called
in school was the worst thing that could
ever happen to you you had to be as
hyper masculine as possible to fit in i
always got along with theater kids i
always got a lot with gay kids and girls
and so i was like okay this is like my
people
but
i don't know
like everyone keeps telling me that i am
gay
and i'm like
seven and then american idol happens i
was like oh he's gay and i'm like okay
well now i have to say no because at
this point they're forcing me to
make a decision sanjaya also revealed
that he sadly received advice to remain
coy about his sexuality oh my publicist
all of it they're like oh just like
tell everyone you're single be ambiguous
be you know like no one needs to know
anything about anything because you
don't want to lose your fans i'm like
okay but why am i manipulating what i
know of myself
to figure out what kind of fans i'm
going to get because i'm still trying to
discover
who i am well sanjaya is now living his
best most authentic life and really
isn't worried about what people think
at this point i don't really care about
what people know of my sexuality and if
i'm going to
like if i
got in a serious long-term relationship
with a guy i would bring him to my
family and they'd be like oh cool a
couple of my cousins have
are bi as well and have brought home
you know
gay partners
and then come and marry someone else and
it's like it becomes a big deal and then
it's not and then it just holds and i'm
like i don't you know unless it's
something serious it's not really their
business and he also reflected on how it
felt to have former american idol judge
simon cowell be quite vocal about not
being a fan a hit on what he would say
to simon today i was very aware of
the fact that he's being paid to say
these things uh he actually came to me
at a after party after the finale
i was like i just need to say
like i have so much respect for you
in how
much grace you took my comments with
it's really sad that this is what you
have to do to be
somebody or whatever you want but you
have chosen this path in your life so
that's fine
thank you thank you for
uh showing me exactly what the industry
is about and teaching me that it's not
necessarily what i needed to involve
myself in
hey thanks for watching et canada if you
want more queer entertainment news and
exclusive interviews be sure to
subscribe and check out these videos